for the last week what we see that  the level of humanitarian support a  little bit uh  down  we hope that  it will some pulse to to find new  resources  and because of russia aggression are  increasing and they are bombing uh  surveillance so  we need more humanitarian support  support from  our partners what we what we are asking  if you can support please support right  now don't wait for for weeks or months  because we need the support right now i  understand it they had all the issues  that um  pre-existed the war and the chronic  issues um and a whole new set of issues  from uh  the invasion the bombing the targeting  civilians so in addition to the overall  needs that existed that have been  largely disrupted by the war  they there's a whole new set of injuries  traumatic care acute victims and  obviously a huge dislocation of millions  of people within the country and  millions who fled